well I'm I'm big into men's rights so
that's what the channel is about you
as a woman yeah yeah I think I think
that men need to be advocated for too I
think like there's always women's rights
we don't ever talk about men okay I
agree but like overall you as a woman
who have clearly historically
systematically been oppressed how can
you then say you advocate for men's
right well because I I don't believe
I've been oppressed
no okay I'll give I'll give you an
example
yeah I don't I don't believe women have
been impressed and this woman tonight
men's hands around my throat tonight
leave a place a bar down the street
hands around her throat and said you're
too much for me you're too pretty I I
can't deal with you I've been told that
I was going to get because I didn't want
to get home with someone I've been told
I've got date in my drink because I
don't want to go home with someone and
you're trying to tell me women haven't
been oppressed I don't know not by and
large men men get assaulted too
and I'm saying can I need you to let me
talk okay because if we're gonna have it
we're gonna have like her like yelling
at me it's not really productive so it's
like wow so I'm saying I'm saying like
men get assaulted and they're not taken
seriously like if a woman gets assault
like what happened with Amber hurt she
came forward people just automatically
believed her and she was able to accuse
a man of things that he didn't even do
and that's a man with power money and
privilege what happens to the average
guy that happens to you like we like we
had a whole movement called believe yeah
so it's like if that happened to a rich
powerful man what does that mean for the
average guy and like that doesn't happen
to women like women automatically are
believed where men aren't and like
because it happens from a history like
women are in a place of like lower power
so how how could we say that we're at a
place of lower power when we never had
to fight in Wars men were the ones that
were forced to go out and fight and
protect women where women women didn't
even have the option to go and fight
because they were seen as too weak women
didn't actually so you might not know
this women didn't actually want the
right to vote because it came with being
drafted so if you if you surveyed women
a hundred years ago do you want the
right to vote Yes or No most said no
because they had to be drafted so okay
they didn't want to do that I don't know
the facts behind that but I just don't
see how that could possibly be true if
they suffrage at you like movement like
how is that suffrage it was actually
started in um New York and it was
started by men it wasn't started by
women okay really yeah it was in Seneca
Falls New York
um I can't remember the exact year off
the top of my head but yeah it wasn't
started but it was a group of 300 people
and the majority were men please help me
okay they go please help yeah and so I I
just think men like they're they're not
they're not taken seriously when they
have claims of assault and that's a real
problem
so even even in this conversation when I
say like that I think men have a problem
like it's always women have to come
forward and say well what about our
problems and we're talking about the
point you're coming across of like men
don't have the voice to be saying oh
I've been assaulted whatever I see that
point especially like being a gay male
or whatever like it takes a lot for
someone to come out and be like okay
I've I've been a solid like walking down
the street or whatever but I just think
it's kind of like rude for your argument
to be then that women don't have
oppression or whatever like that no I I
just don't think we have in 2022 you
have so much privilege as a young pretty
girl in my workplace the work of like
hierarchy it's like 75 percent male to
women so do you know do you know why
that is why because men pick harder jobs
men work more hours no no if you look at
so and I'm just saying like if you just
Google like Google what percent of what
percent of women are plumbers what
percent so Plumbing electricians okay I
understand that but that's different
that's society telling men that they
should become plumbers that's not women
not becoming plumbers or getting a
hard-working job so I I used to think
that too right I literally I used to
think that but when you look at
countries that are more so if you look
do a list of countries right and you
pick the countries that are more free
and then do the countries that are the
least free for women and it's pretty
easy to like to pick those you go to the
Scandinavian countries there's more free
if you go to the like Saudi Arabia last
Freight the pay Gap gets bigger the more
Choice women have which seems to
indicate that women pick jobs that make
less money when they're given more
Choice okay so I haven't looked into
that so I can't really comment on that
yeah
expect you to come into knowing
everything yeah but so I just think a
lot of times the narrative is like that
women are oppressed and I genuinely
think that a lot of men have it harder
than us and we don't advocate for them
like like for example if if I get
married and I get a divorce um who's the
one collecting child support and in the
U.S there are men that commit suicide
over going into so much debt over child
support like like there are women
stealing condoms from the NBA trying to
get pregnant like and so it's just like
these are men's issues that I think are
important I feel like it's very
different like we're in the UK you can't
really I don't think in terms of looking
at America's statistics it shouldn't
really be applied to the UK it's very
it's a it's a very different climate the
UK the UK has similar problems they also
have child support like I've interviewed
men on the channel That come forward and
say like yeah that girl tried to get
like like she told me she was on birth
control to try to get pregnant it's
definitely an issue and like I've heard
of that before but that is very based on
the individual I don't know I just think
as a woman are you saying you're not a
feminist no I wouldn't call myself a
feminist because I just I think in 2022
what am I fighting for we have all the
rights okay Alex and that's crazy
well you know what what right do I not
have so do you do you go to nightclubs
no
no don't drink there you go so I think
that is mainly your issue so you you
don't go to nightclubs you don't put
yourself and I guess it's kind of like
oh just a woman put herself in that
position but it's not if you're going on
a night out you're having fun that's you
deciding I'm gonna go have my friends
and then a man a man is taking advantage
of you you shouldn't then be blamed for
oh I wore a short dress like I was going
hard having fun like before you were
saying if a girl wears red lipstick like
she's asking for it no I didn't say that
we have the recording okay so so no I'm
not sure yeah so I didn't say she along
the lines oh no I wasn't saying she's
asking for it I'm saying that's what it
indicates sexual arousal I'm saying so
like I think that's weird because in my
head as a student who studies fashion
yeah red lipstick I've seen as like
fashionable it's like a catwalk like red
lipstick is a very prominent thing in
fashion it's not oh I'm I'm sexually
active like I want people to have sex
with me it might not be intentional but
like there's reasons that like like that
we put the makeup on the way we do it
like like like Mass Garrett mascara
indicates bigger eyes like men are
attracted to bigger eyes
like to me you want to come in I just
think that's down to you like if you're
playing mascara on to have bigger eyes
and you're thinking oh I'm gonna have
bigger eyes to attract a man and that's
down to you did you know what's
interesting when I do these interviews
like it's not it's not the men who are
rude to me it's always the women and
it's always like I almost got like a
girl was trying to attack me like
honestly like I'm saying like genuinely
I'm more afraid of getting attacked by
women than I am by men but I just think
that's because you're not showing
yourself as wanting like for a woman I
just think that's because you're not
advocating for women to have like but it
shouldn't be like I am allowed to have a
different opinion than a woman so so
like I think as women if you're really a
feminist you should support women that
have different opinions than you I think
and so I'm saying like when I when I
when I can I just finish like yeah so
like when I'm doing these Street on
interviews it's very frustrating because
the women that say they're advocating
for me are the same ones trying to throw
hands because the people that are
advocating for you you're completely
backfiring to them and saying you're not
advocating for women at all no I'm
saying they're not advocating for me
because I should be out like it's a
conversation for yourself you're saying
you're not a feminist so you don't want
equal rights you just wanted no no
that's not what I said I'm saying we
have you I'm saying feminist sorry I'm
not a feminist because we have all the
rights we need anything you do so I'm
asking what law or policy do we need in
2022 I just think it should be easy
because like we're so oppressed so
what's what's one okay well I don't know
a price intensive laws but I know a
price in terms of society you said you
don't go clubbing so my friends they go
clubbing and they get sexually abused
almost people grab them people touch
them and it's inappropriate you don't
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime you're not entitled to
safety